تحدث إلينا أكثر قليلاً حول سبب كون
الآيات الشيطانية مثيرة للجدل للغاية ،
أعني أنها نوع من
الحبكة متعددة الطبقات ، فهي تتبع نوعين
من الرجال الهنود المسلمين الذين يعيشون في المملكة المتحدة ،
أحدهم في أعقاب
حادث تحطم طائرة يحدث له
أحلم بنوع من الحلم الخيالي
عن حياة النبي محمد ،
ورأى الكثير من الناس أنه ربما يكون
الاستهزاء بالإسلام يسخر من دينهم
فقط يعطينا المزيد من السياق حول سبب
تسبب هذا الكتاب بالذات في الكثير من
الغضب خاصة بين بعض الناس
وقد كان كذلك.  محظور في عدد من
البلدان ،
نعم ،
هناك العديد من المشكلات المختلفة التي
يواجهها بعض الأشخاص ويجب أن أقول إن بعض
الناس لا يثيرها الجميع في العالم الإسلامي ،
على سبيل المثال في الشخصية التي
تم تفسيرها على أنها محمد ،
يستخدم اسمًا مختلفًا ولكنه  اسم
استخدمه المسيحيون
خلال الحروب الصليبية
كمصطلح ازدرائي لمحمد ،
كما أن الإشارة أه إلى
الآيات الشيطانية هي آيات  في القرآن
الذي يبدو أنه أخرجه محمد من
أنه حصل عليه في البداية ثم
أخرجه وهناك بعض الجدل
حول ذلك وتمحور الكتاب حول ذلك
الذي اعتبره البعض أه كفريًا
وبشكل عام الإيحاء
الذي يقدمه الكتاب وهو أن  القرآن في
الواقع ليس عملاً إلهيًا ولكن
عمل الإنسان ربما يكون
سببًا آخر لسبب اعتراض العديد من
الأشخاص عليه ولكن أعتقد
أنه من المهم أيضًا إدراك
أن هذا كان جدالًا محليًا
وصغيرًا إلى أن
أه آية الله الإيراني  قرر الخميني رفعها
وتصعيدها والقضية التي تقاتل من أجلها وهذا
جعلها قضية أكبر بكثير لها
تداعيات دولية.